so you said wisdom is universal yeah
what about wealth and power yeah well uh
well i guess it depends on what you mean
by power so i think of power as the
ability to to influence a large number
of people yeah so um
and this is one of the interesting
things about
the fact that cash economies are so
are evolutionarily very recent
in that we're people are like so so i
guess recently or it's about to happen
uh that um elon musk is gonna
buy a twitter okay where is it happen is
it happen already yeah okay so they said
like the the
wealthiest or one of the wealthiest men
on earth has now purchased the most
influential media platform
on earth and so
obviously you or i couldn't um
compete with elon musk and
for the purchase of twitter and so
uh the fact
that cash economies allow the
stockpiling of unprecedented amounts of
wealth
produces these tremendous power
differentials that that didn't exist in
in over most of human evolutionary
history
um so their wealth is power but you can
also be
um
the power can be attained through other
ways yeah but but but i would say that
the interesting thing about
wealth is that it's
an infinitely fungible resource
so you can
use it and translate it into
many many other things like buying a
buying twitter or buying a big house or
or even
getting mates or
an artificial um in
i don't know if you don't want to get
into that at all but i need to have
these
sex dolls or
virtual virtual reality sex that some
people are are developing if you have
enough resources you can purchase things
like that so
you can trans you can translate wealth
into a variety of other
tangible things in ways that that you
couldn't ancestrally
so
that's one really powerful thing but
there is still power
that's correlated but not
intricately connected to what wealth
which is like being leaders of nations
like technically the president of the
united states salary is not very high
right
presidents and and then you look you go
outside of that into the half of the
world that's living under authoritarian
regimes you have dictators
and there's uh
those those are very powerful usually
men
and
presumably there's some
value there in the meeting selection
aspect yeah yeah absolutely and and it's
not by chance that um
most of them are men
um and this is
gonna sound
strange or and hopefully not offensive
to people but
if you ask the question why are why is
it the case that men are in positions of
power
so much more so than than women well in
part it can be traced to women's mate
preferences so it's one of the sex
differences that women have
over evolutionary time preferred men who
had power status resources
etc and what that has done is it's
created selection pressure on men to
attach a high motivational priority
to clawing their way up the status
hierarchy
and and
studies of uh time
allocation distribution show this where
men
are they're more willing to sacrifice
their their friends their grandmother
their kin or whatever to claw their way
up to the top of status hierarchies
women much less women
spend more effort maintaining
relationships with their can through
their friends their friend networks and
so forth and so
um and and so in a way uh so
you could say not only are you uh not
only are men in positions of power more
than women now you're blaming women for
why they are and it's not it's not a
matter of blame but i think that
that what i just outlined is is an
essential part of the causal process the
co-evolution of women's mate preferences
with men's motivational priorities